i think as an entrepreneur the key is
actually to get used to it to to accept
it as a reality that the things are
going to be like that sometimes you'll
find a great base of customers um and
then they'll disappear they'll choose
something else they'll uh they'll
they'll no longer be excited about your
product this happens all the time and
then you you just have to be able to be
flexible enough to move to a different
product to uh to reinvent yourself
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders the future
of delivery and fulfillment is here and
i'm joined today by idan hilshko
co-founder of avo a fast-growing
ecommerce startup focused on reducing
costs for consumers by aggregating
demand before starting avo he then
started a couple of other companies and
was also an early employee at monday.com
he was also the founder of a podcast
called startup camel where he
interviewed over 80 founders from the
israeli startup scene
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm great yeah very hot today but uh
excited to be on the show well i'm
really excited to be catching you here
in israel in tel aviv we're at the avo
offices in your specifically this
location
but but you're growing an incredible
company changing your paradigms and
changing the way we think about the
deliveries and goods and and and
everything that comes in between uh but
most importantly you're bringing with
you
you know what it means to be an
entrepreneur and i'm really excited to
hear your perspective on your own
journey uh previously vp customer
success at monday yeah an incredible
company now chief customer officer of
ava and co-founder
idan before we get to avo itself tell me
a little bit about your own trajectory
and and why you choose to be an
entrepreneur
um that's a good question uh
i think that you know
it starts from uh kind of uh
your your perception of you know it
would sound like a like a big uh thing
but but your your perception of life
like what is what does it mean to live
at all uh as a general concept and to me
uh you know
because i don't believe in like
afterlife or anything like that i i
think that we are here for a next period
of time and we need to do our best
during that time and uh to me that was
always like that was
how i how i think about this concept of
like where do i want to be and i think
to me
i really wanted to to build something
and see something becoming and
becoming uh huge and and
and importantly make some kind of a dent
in the world and an impact and i didn't
know exactly how it's going to happen
but you know this is my way of making
some kind of an impact on the world so
amazing and so today as chief customer
officer of avo
you know you're deciding to go on this
entrepreneurial journey before we get to
the more personal aspects what is alpha
doing you know in high level perspective
and and how how is it changing a lot of
the the you know the background thinking
that we used to have right um okay so
basically um
when when we started the company we we
looked at all the other e-commerce
companies in the world and we noticed
that they all work in more or less the
same way the same way amazon started
working um back in 1994
um is how most e-commerce companies work
today so what does it mean it means that
you start you you open
an online website right um you uh get
customers via facebook and google so you
market you pay a lot of money to
facebook and google so you acquire
customers and then the other part after
you acquire the customer you have to
fulfill so you deliver to them
usually via third parties like fedex ups
or the the mail in your local mail
system now
the problem with that is the huge costs
so customer acquisition is very
expensive
and and delete delivery costs and
fulfillment costs are extremely
expensive so for you as as a as a
supplier uh you are left with a very
small margin and many many of those
companies don't survive because of that
so we decided okay this this seems to be
a problematic way of doing things and we
want to do it in a totally different way
and the way we chose was we thought okay
if we could find a place where there's a
lot of demand aggregated and aggregation
is the main the key here if we could
aggregate demand we can save a lot of
money and a lot of the costs on the the
fulfillment obviously because you
fulfill to one location so that's pretty
easy but then it's easy to understand
but then the other thing is you can also
market in that specific place
and by doing so you you you save a lot
of the costs associated with customer
acquisition so
you you have
you know you have a a large improvement
in the in the economics of the whole
business and that's how we started
that's the focus of the company and
that's exactly what we do we go to
areas um that have a lot of people you
know have a lot of people in in them uh
so example could be uh residential
buildings commercial buildings um it
could be hospitals could be army bases
could be anything any place where you
have a can you can use small communities
um and and you open a an online store
for that community
you market in that in inside that
community and you fulfill you fulfill to
that community and uh that's that's what
we do so you know it obviously includes
something that today a lot of people
like to say which is like vertical
integration which means that we control
the supply so we have our own warehouses
right own delivery vans and our own
marketing we have the entire supply
chain in in avo and uh and that's
obviously
um very complicated but on the other
hand it's much
it's
the business model much more uh i think
advanced or or uh profitable
than many other e-commerce companies and
obviously it's a win-win because also
the customer has a much better
experience right having you being in all
parts of the supply action and i think
we can talk for hours about well maybe i
should add one more thing because i i
forgot so
you know you mentioned the customer
which is of course the key here right
and because of everything i described we
have the this whole vertical integration
and we have the uh the we own the
fulfillment and the marketing and
everything around it then for the
customer we can offer something that
nobody else can offer which is free same
day delivery with no minimum order so it
means that you can order a single
avocado from us that's why you can call
the company and have it delivered to
you the same day with no delivery fee
and that is something that i think no
other uh business model
can survive with in a in a in um
um you know in in a cost effective way
and that makes a lot of sense we can
spend hours talking about all this but
what i'm really excited about is to hear
your own personal entrepreneurial
endeavor yeah you're deciding to go on
this journey
reimagining a new business model for a
really complicated world i'm sure it's
like a roller coaster that we all know
the different graphs
walk me through a little bit your own
perspective of what it means to be an
entrepreneur now
and and some of the key insights that
you've gained with you over the last
while
um sure so i think i think there are a
few uh really important things that that
i've learned that i i don't know
something you know it's different for
everybody uh every person that starts
from a different point in life and
experience different things but i think
uh there are a few things that i can i
can share maybe that could potentially
help someone else uh so the first thing
is
that it's sometimes very very hard
to
convince people
that what you're imagining
is going to be real and uh it's it's
very hard to estimate how how difficult
it is because people
and in general it doesn't matter if it's
investors employees uh you know uh
family members it could be anyone uh
it's very difficult to to take a dream
that you have in your head and
understanding that you have in your head
and explain it to them and explain why
things will happen the way uh you
believe that they will happen and
and i think once you
digest this this
this
piece of the world and this uh this
reality uh things become much easier
because you meet someone it could be an
investor it could be anyone and you talk
to them and you try to explain and your
vision and sometimes it takes a long
time and you're not you're not
disappointed if they don't understand
because you you you understand that
it takes time it just takes time and a
lot of explaining and a lot of and a lot
of um
a lot of proof so and that's why
one of the things the first thing that
happened to us um we started the company
in 2017 2018 uh summer
18 we got accepted to white combinator
that was a big thing for us uh not
because not only because uh y combinator
is the best accelerator in the world and
all of that
mainly because i think what they helped
us understand is what to focus on and
they really they really say hey look you
have a company you don't have a lot of
time right you have you know a little
bit of cash from your savings you need
to prove something right so they say
look at your business ask yourself what
is the main metric that you're going to
focus on
and run
and and improve that right to the max
and in our case they said okay what's
your main metric right now how many
companies
you have on on you know working with you
great why don't you bring 50 what are
you bringing 100 just run around all day
non-stop don't think about improving the
product don't think about anything else
just focus on that that was extremely
helpful so i think that's a that's a
very important uh element of the
that i understood so
so to conclude this part i would say you
know really try to understand that it
takes a lot of time and energy to
convince people and uh and and it's a
journey it takes time so that's the
first thing and
yes so that's that's one thing another
thing that i think is really important
to understand is that a lot of times
when i speak to people they said
you know
that they think about entrepreneurship
or stuff like that they say oh well um
this and that had a great idea in the
beginning that's why they succeeded and
the reality is
that uh i like to compare it to finding
oil
it takes time to find oil but it's not
the same for everyone some people go to
the backyard
their backyard they dig a they
find oil right but many other people
would take many many years to find oil
so it's like that you need to accept
that reality and you need to if you
decided to to be to to start on the
search you need to accept the fact that
it's it's not necessarily that all the
great startups had a fantastic idea some
of them some of them did and it you know
succeeded on on day one many of them
didn't there there are so many
you know many stories of companies that
had a bad idea and then changed it and
and uh and
use their agility to find the right uh
the right solution or the right product
and there are even more interesting uh
um stories of people that had a great
idea but came into a cro
crashed into a wall at some point or or
you know face the wall and had to go
around it and then sometimes even if
your great idea i think one of the best
stories that i like is is uh ben
horowitz from from the other things
about hard things and uh
it's really interesting he took a
company from zero to i think a billion
dollar
then
bubble burst
going down to 30 million valuation and
then going up back back up to 1.6
billion and selling it and with a
totally different product like it
started from hardware completely changed
the company going to uh software and i
think there are many many stories like
that of totally changing your your path
and and the way you you you operate or
the way your computer operates and it's
about agility and being able to to
change
and
being flexible and open to to new ideas
and one of the things that i think
you're mentioning here is also the
confirmation bias that we and also the
young generation probably has you know
we're reading techcrunch crunchbase and
we're seeing all these crazy things
happening in the market
these are not overnight successes when
i'm looking online and i'm researching
in preparation for this episode
i'm looking at what you're doing with
avon i'm shocked i'm i'm like wow this
is incredible how do they do it so
quickly this is amazing but then you're
saying well we actually started in 2017
2018. three years that's a lot of days
that's almost a thousand days of really
hard work of blood sweat and tears
and but but from an outsider's
perspective it may seem so quick
yeah but it's a journey it's
a long journey and i think if you look
also if you look at the average of the
companies that go to an ipo you'll see
it's not like a year or two i think the
average is like 10 years it's like yes a
long long journey and and probably a lot
of them have changed completely along
the way you know um
i i was one of the first employees of
monday and
monday changed when i joined monday it
was the post it was yeah but the the
funny thing when i
joined monday it was after the company
have tried
different the founders and the the
earlier team tried several things that
didn't work and adjusted and found a new
product and then started developing that
one uh that product and and you know we
need to remember also at avo we we in
the first
uh until 2000 until 2020 we were
entirely focused on residential on
commercial buildings um and that's our
entire focus and then you know kovitz
started and we had to figure it out
because because basically everyone
you know nobody showed up into in the
offices anymore we had to find a way
around it and
we put in a lot of hard work in trying
to understand how to get into
residential buildings and we figured it
out but it was a lot of hard work it's
not easy and i think there's probably a
lot of hard work
in the future for us because it just
that's the way it is but i think as an
entrepreneur the key is actually to get
used to it to to accept it as a reality
that the things are going to be like
that sometimes you'll find a great base
of customers um and then they'll
disappear they'll choose something else
they'll uh they'll
they'll no longer be excited about your
product this happens all the time and
then you you just have to be able to be
flexible enough to move to a different
product to uh to reinvent yourself and i
think actually you know that's the
exciting part reinventing yourself
over and over again and that's actually
fun what is what is happening on a
personal level though as you're trying
to redefine yourself you know you're
basically saying let's take all the
different rejections that we get and
turn them upside down and use them to to
become a better version of ourselves
right
but you ca it can't be an easy process
that you're doing to yourself what did
you learn
having practicing this pretty much what
i'm guessing on a daily basis in one way
or another
yeah uh i think that it's
i learned
a lot of things about like that
you know during the last like four years
uh i think i really learned about a lot
about like the ability um the importance
of um
what uh
what someone may call uh being radically
open-minded uh that's super important in
my opinion um
to understand that you know there
are there are many things you're trying
to do um we've tried many things along
the way that i thought personally
will never work and worked amazingly
there were many things that i thought
would be a great success but
were
you know totally disaster and i think
the more you you you experience that and
that's only experience can tell it can
teach you like you try something try it
again and then after you see that it's
very hard to predict and
you accept it as a reality it's just
simply you know super difficult to
predict uh what's going to be the result
and you just have to experiment with a
lot of things and i think that's the key
if you understand
the the value of experimenting a lot um
i think that that really gives you an
edge as an entrepreneur um and and so
that's why i also think you know if you
go back to the concept of having a great
idea
um even if you have a great idea but
you're not flexible enough
then
very soon you'll you'll hit a wall
and then you will probably crash into it
because if you are not i actually i
think in a way it's better to start with
a not a great idea and to have to evolve
into a better idea because that forces
you into trying different things and
being flexible about and
about about the agility and being um
you know and understanding that that
it's
what we've done so far is not
necessarily what we're gonna do in the
future um and the more you and your team
understand that uh the better the
company is going to be and you know
amazon is obviously the best example in
the world for that right because they
have
started and did you know probably we
don't even know about most of the
businesses that they've started and
failed right and shut down and even some
of them were big you know like the fire
phone or you know big uh things that
failed uh but but still they keep on
doing it they have a culture of
reinventing re you know and and i think
we're trying to to do the same
you done i i love your perspective and i
love your journey i love avon and you
know it's a huge israeli pride
and thank you for taking the time to
share this with me i really appreciate
how busy you are i have three more
questions for you not about avvo not
about the entrepreneurial journey but
about yourself
take me back to middle school what
really fascinates you as a kid you're
going through life
what what really sparks your curiosity
um i think that what really i i was
really excited about space oh really
yeah i think that space is really really
interesting uh i think a lot of people
think that and i think obviously you
know there are a lot of people who
thought
of space is an interesting thing and
still think about it uh it's really just
huge and you know our existence in in
this uh small uh small earth uh you know
floating in spaces it's pretty amazing
and you know it's just
sparked your imagination and yeah now we
can obviously start going to space
maybe yeah maybe maybe we might take
some time hey what really inspires you
today as you go day by day either as a
co-founder
as a customer obsession you know role
as a you know as a thought leader
what really inspires you um i think
i think that you know
inspiration is actually a very good very
important thing in life and i think
people underestimate the value of it
it's actually a very good question
because i think that your every one of
us
should should um should push their or
should create a lot of inspiration for
themselves all the time people don't i
think a lot of people don't do it uh and
i think for me i find a lot of
inspiration in actually listening to
other people's story other other uh
other teams other uh other builders and
their stories and it could be anything
from
uh historical figures to uh to stories
of other entrepreneurs and and you know
on during that time even before i
started the company i would read and i
still do read a lot of biographies of
and you know um
everyone who have ever built something
interesting from warren buffett to steve
jobs uh to you know anyone i i've read
uh so many books uh phil knight's story
and uh
of course shoe dog is amazing there are
many many stories and many podcasts so
those kind of things uh really excite me
and also i think for me personally
um i was you know i like took a part in
in the in the story of you know in the
journey of monday uh and i think the
founders there was were also very
inspiring and the results that they have
achieved inspire thought which is you
know yeah i love it and what are three
words would you describe yourself um i
think that
the first one would probably be
curiosity um i'm really curious and i
just really like
um
really like to
uh
dig into areas that i don't know and
learning and just just listening to
many things um sometimes they're you
know in in my space
some sometimes uh in totally different
uh places and and i like to actually
connect them to one
big big story and for example um i'm
like i'm a musician so i like to find
ways to connect that into my day-to-day
work on my day-to-day
perception uh
that's one thing um the other thing i
would say is
um
maybe
relentlessness in a way um because i
think i i could um i could get going um
with
with something that i focus on
um
for for a long time and uh and i've i've
done it several times with with but
whether it's customers
or or trying to drive change through a
company or trying to
um figure out a solution to a problem
um and that translate also to your
personal life this relentlessness to
to get something done to do something
right
um i would say
that
in in a way yes i mean i'm very um i'm
i don't like to live things that are not
solved so whether it's in relationships
i'm
i think it's really important to me to
solve the issue to to get to the bottom
of that uh i think there i i i rarely
have a uh you know i really uh have a
disagreement with someone that i don't
come
that i don't um insist on on solving
closing and closing it and on solving it
and understanding why did i made someone
angry why did i make them angry could i
could i fix it and most of the time i
can and which is great um so i think
that's another thing i do yeah i think
that's one another part of it and the
third word i would say creative i really
like
creating things uh again going back to
music um but regardless like in in in a
company setting i would say really like
being a part of of marketing uh
kind of
debates or or
interactions um i also like the
being being a part of
the creative team working on our
warehouse uh processes
anything around that i really like the
creative process
um so you know that's
thank you very much this is amazing
thank you for sharing the time the
honesty and the openness best of luck
with avo and stay safe and still
[Music]